the Broward County Sheriff makes a
complete ass of himself high school
classmates of shooting victims take it
way too far and Democrats tried to
defend the FBI over the steel doughsay
had lots to get to i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
so here we are in beautiful scenic
Minnesota I'm speaking the University of
Minnesota tonight
I've been shuttled off campus to what
they call the cow college I guess which
is the agriculture school which is at
least a mile away I believe from the
main campus where I will be doing my
speech tonight I look forward to seeing
everybody there we'll talk a little bit
more about that plus I have some good
news for my producer Mathis in the stuff
that I like a little bit later in the
show but before we get to any of this
stuff first I want to say thank you to
our new sponsors over at Lending Club so
everybody needs a helping hand sometimes
a lot of folks who need a little bit of
extra money for wedding or you have
medical expenses or you have credit card
debt
well sometimes a little money can make a
pretty big difference and you can make
it happen over at Lending Club com so
here's what Lending Club does they give
you low ad access to low rates on loans
up to $40,000 for almost any purpose you
take control of your debt finance major
purpose purchase or make those home
improvements it's particularly good if I
already have credit card debt and you
want to take out a loan to get that APR
down for example it's easier than going
to a bank and offers lower rates than
high interest credit cards go to Lending
Club com enter how much money you need
and you can see if you're approved in
just minutes then you pick the offer
that is right for you and the money can
be in your accounts in just a matter of
days it is that simple for more than 10
years Lending Club has helped millions
of people with over thirty 1 billion
dollars in loan so here's how it works
go to Lending Club dot-com /ban and
there you can check your rate for free
this will not impact your credit score
so that's good news number one then
Lending Club com slash been lending
club.com safe and then it gives you a
bunch of different options and Lending
Club lets you know whether you're
approved for loaning a loan via Lending
Club so go to Lending Club comm check
you're right for Freeland and club.com
slash been and when you do you can check
your rate for free again this is the
best way that you can get one of these
loans that for less than $40,000 again I
have friends who've tried this for
weddings
I know family members who are looking at
it for various house expenses you don't
want to take all that out on a credit
card that can jump to 1 million percent
APR after three months of not paying it
that's why you go to Lending Club comm
slash Bend and you get loans through
Lending Club all loans made by web Bank
member of FDIC Equal Housing lender go
check it out right now Lending Club comm
slash been again there's not a better
way to get a loan than Lending Club
dot-com slash Bend that also want
know that we sent you alright so but
begin today with the news update on what
we now know about what happened in
parkland so we now know from the UK
Daily Mail then not only was everybody
around the shooter in parkland actually
calling the the police over all of this
we now know that the shooter himself
called the police on himself according
to the Daily Mail it has been revealed
that the Florida school shooter who
killed 17 people after he opened fire
and Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School
called the police distressed after his
mother passed away just a few months ago
he called authorities just after
Thanksgiving saying he had been in a
fight and was struggling with the death
of his mother he said the thing is I
lost my mother a couple of weeks ago so
I'm dealing with a bunch of things right
now on January 5th a woman who knew the
shooter called the FBI tip line and said
quote I know he's going to explode she
said her biggest fear was that he might
resort to entering a school and just
start shooting the place up
four days later of course he did exactly
that so warning after warning after
warning after warning Scott Israel is
the is the sheriff of Broward County
who's made a complete fool of himself he
came out earlier last late last week and
he suggested that there weren't quite as
many calls to the house as he had once
been accused of apparently there are
people saying there are 39 different
calls to the house by the police because
of all the warnings about the shooter he
said no no no was only 23 only one
problem according to BuzzFeed that is
not true they say Broward County
sheriff's officials said in a statement
late Saturday they responded only to 23
calls involving suspected Florida
shooter or his family over the years but
records obtained by BuzzFeed news show
at least 45 responses since 2008 the
number of calls made over the years
involving the shooter or his family
according to the call records are nearly
twice the number publicly disclosed by
the department on Saturday night they
had released a statement pushing back on
reports they had been called to more
than 23 incidents released by the
department they also put out a statement
suggesting that it was not true as we
reported on Friday that or a CNN report
on Friday that there were four different
deputies standing outside the shooting
with their guns drawn refusing to go in
but then they admitted that they
actually did not know whether that was
the case or not
so just absolute malfeasance ridiculous
malfeasance the idea that anybody's
going to give up their gun because the
authorities are gonna take care of them
when the authorities clearly are not
taking care of them yeah good luck with
that good
but that now Second Amendment advocates
gonna sit around waiting for you to show
up when you prove that you can't even
show up to the school shooting when you
have an armed school officer there so
just to show how ridiculous this is
Scott Israel finally appears with Jake
Tapper on Sunday morning I was very
critical of Jake and his role in what I
thought was just an absolute debacle
last week on CNN they had a two-hour CNN
Town Hall with Dana lash from the NRA
and Senator Marco Rubio and Senator Bill
Nelson the Democrat who was a hero to
the crowd for suggesting that they
oughta ban all semi-automatic weapons
and I thought Jake did not do a good job
of handling that situation I thought the
thing was to set up from the beginning I
thought it was an emotional manipulation
move I thought it had nothing to do with
disseminating important information to
the public it was just a way to for
people to vent their spleen and ire at
Dana and at Rubio to people who had
nothing to do with the shooting while
completely ignoring Scott Israel Scott
Israel the Broward County Sheriff was
there too when as you recall he ripped
into Dana lash he ripped into Rubio he
suggested that these were the people at
fault not him he had done a wonderful
job well then it came out literally
within 48 hours that there was a deputy
on the grounds who did nothing that the
police department had gotten warning
after warning after warning after
warning nearly 40 times for more than 40
times according to BuzzFeed and did
nothing and he went on stage with Dana
lash and he ripped her up and down
knowing that the culpability was for
those part hits so on Sunday he comes
back and he does his sit-down with Jake
Tapper and Jake this time does a really
good job Jake grills him and Jake makes
him look pretty bad this exchange is
just astonishing Scott Israel the
sheriff of Broward County explaining
that actually in reality his leadership
was just amazing his leadership was
actually incredible Jake I could only
take responsibility for what I knew
about ie exercises my due diligence
I've given amazing leadership to this
agency leaders I've work yes Jake
this is there's a lot of things we've
done throughout this this is a you don't
measure a person's leadership by a
deputy not going into a these deputies
receive the training they needed maybe
they mention somebody's leadership
whether or not they protect the
community in this case you've listed 23
incidents before the shooting involving
the shooter and still nothing was done
to keep guns out of his hands to make
sure that there were
school was protected to make sure you
were keeping an eye on him your deputy
actually got failed I don't understand
how you can sit there and claim amazing
leadership okay but Scott Israel did
anyway I'm good for tapper for calling
him on it's too bad that they didn't
have this information before that Town
Hall when Israel was allowed to rant and
rave around the stage like a maniac
blaming everybody but himself
tapper went further than this he said
are you really not taking any
responsibility here he grilled Israel
for suggesting that that everything was
hunky-dory I hear his tapper going off
on Scott Israel again deputies make
mistakes police officers make mistakes
we all make mistakes but it's not the
responsibility of the general or the
president if you have a deserter you
look into this we're looking into this
aggressively and we'll we'll take care
of it and justice will be served are you
really not taking any responsibility for
the multiple red flags that were brought
to the attention of the Broward
Sheriff's Office about this shooter
before the incident whether it was
people near him close to him calling the
choice we got I mean really what the
hell is he talking about when when
Israel says that this is like the
president being responsible for a
deserter no this is not like the
deserter there you have an entire chain
of command and the deserter is punished
in some cases with jail time and in in
rare cases with actual death penalty in
this case not only was there one deputy
there there may have been four deputies
there who did nothing and again there
were dozens and dozens and dozens of
warnings if there were dozens of
warnings that there was an attack about
to happen a specific learning not just a
general warning specific warnings there
was an attack about to happen on 9/11
and the President of the United States
ignored morning after warning after
warning after warning that was brought
to him and all of his people did that
and then an attack took place and three
thousand Americans died do you think
that impeachment might be on the table
the answer is yes hey people were
talking about how Bush was was
neglectful of 9/11 based on one vague
warning that airplanes might be used for
a terror attack at some point in the
future one warning that I'm not even
sure Bush saw at any point he was ripped
up and down for that Israel's department
was told dozens and dozens of times 45
separate times that the shooter the
shooter himself called the police
department basically said stop me and
the police department didn't do anything
and there's Israel claiming that there
was nothing there what's even worse is
that Israel goes ahead and he says that
he's heard reports before the town hall
took place that his deputy
did not charge into the fray okay here's
Israel admitting that he went on
national television and by omission lied
to the American public repeatedly during
that special and tried to misdirect
attention away from himself this is I
mean this guy is just a despicable human
being here here he is did you know it
then did you know it Wednesday night it
was spoken about during that earlier
during that day I'm not on a time line
for TV or any news show we need to get
it right we need to get it accurate
we're talking about people's lives we're
talking about a community so he'd heard
before but he's trying to now talk about
what about people's lives and about the
community how about this how about you
go in front of the community and you go
on bended knee and you ask their
forgiveness for all of the the crappy
job that you did here it is just an
amazing thing that he says and it gets
even worse it gets even worse because in
just a second I'm gonna play you what
Israel said when he was asked about what
the department could have done
differently because it truly is an
amazing thing first
okay so Israel is asked about when he
knew that the deputies had not entered
he's asked again by tapper and again he
misdirects the question when did you
find out the deputy Peterson had not
gone into the building how soon after
the shooting did you know that not four
days we uh how many that's the Gators
looked I'm not sure he's not sure he
just didn't know it's just a mystery to
him he can't remember that answer means
that he knew before the Town Hall here
is the one that was really making the
rounds this particular response from
Scott Israel if this guy has a job by
the end of the week that is a blight on
the state of govern the state of
government in Florida and he can be
fired by rick scott rick scott the
florida governor who's a republican
who's come in for a lot of criticism
from israel has said that he wants a
full investigation before he fires
israel that's probably not the worst
move in the world considering that he
doesn't want the partisan blowback he
wants to be able to show case in point
exactly how israel screwed this thing up
so that israel can't claim it's a
partisan hit but if israel had any had
any sort of moral fortitude at all he
would step down obviously he does not
and this quote shows that he does not
look at this this is just astonishing so
israel has asked what he could have done
differently and his answer is just
mind-boggling is mind-boggling you think
that if the Broward Sheriff's Office had
done things differently this shooting
might not have happened
listen if ifs and buts were candy and
nuts you know
Oh J Simpson would still be in a record
books I don't know what that means dead
people and there's a whole long list of
things your department could have done
differently how could listen that's what
that's what after-action reports are
that's for lessons learn reports all for
if ifs and nuts were candies and butts
well what what is even talking about
what kind of what and Tapper says there
are 17 people dead I don't even know
what you're talking about here what are
you even saying and the answer is he
doesn't know what he's saying because
this is complete nonsense he's just
saying random crap because this is what
he's doing to avoid responsibility so
finally he's asked if he's going to
resign and of course the answer's no
he's not going to resign the people
responsible are the ones who took the
calls and didn't follow up on him as it
was with the FBI as it was with with any
with any person leaders cannot leaders
are responsible for the agency but
leaders are not expel responsible for a
person I gave him a gun I gave him a
badge I gave him the training if he
didn't have the heart to go in that's
not my responsibility so I gave her the
gun I gave the training I gave him the
badge but it's not my fault if he didn't
go and how about it's your fault if you
were told nearly 50 times what the
shooter was doing again all of this is
an attempt to misdirect now what's truly
astonishing is you would expect these
survivors you would expect some of the
victims to speak out against Scott
Israel and some of them are there are
some of the shooting victims who are
actually coming out and saying that this
sheriff is a coward and needed something
wrong these are not the ones however
that you're seeing in on CNN you're
seeing them on Fox News you're not
seeing them on MSNBC you're not seeing
them in the mainstream media nearly as
much as you're seeing for example David
hog or or Gonzales the the
seventeen-year-old girl who's been on TV
a lot you're seeing you're seeing those
people you're seeing people who are pro
gun control in CNN and MSNBC a lot but
some of the other survivors you're not
seeing nearly at all so for example
there's a father of a shooting victim
and he came out he said listen the
sheriff is a coward which is pretty
obvious that the sheriff is a coward
here his name is he was a trump
voter he's one of the ones who's at the
White House but he's not been covered
extensively on CNN one deputy that
worked there Peterson he worked there
and he's a coward
he was he stood by the door I know
what's a fact he he could have made it
to the third floor and saved all
victims if he wasn't some little I can't
even words can't even describe what the
way I think about him but I'm not trying
to think about that stuff because that's
just negative and I'm just gonna make me
toxic boof the father of shooting
victims saying the sheriff's deputy was
a coward which is obvious the church
himself has said that but the real
question is is that the sheriff's fault
a survivor a young student named Kyle
cash of he came out he says yeah of
course it's the sheriff's well why are
we even talking about random law-abiding
gun owners across the country instead of
talking about the sheriff it out to the
outrages me that on the CNN Town Hall we
had the sheriff who was virtue signaling
against the NRA and against guns when he
didn't even act properly the the armed
officer at school waited outside and
then him the sheriff and his men for
four minutes let my classmates die while
he sat outside and waited he didn't even
do his job properly and then he comes
around and turns around saying guns are
the issue when he failed to act properly
so unless of course is exactly right but
you're not gonna see how Kyle Kyle cash
you've getting the sorts of following on
Twitter that you're seeing the the other
students get so there are a lot of
people on the Left who are who are
promoting the the as I say I can't
remember her first name and Emma
Gonzalez I believe it's promoting her
saying look how many Twitter followers
she has Kyle cash who've currently has
let's see how many Twitter followers he
has like thirteen point six thousand
Twitter followers I think he is he's
from the school he was there but no
shocked of course no shocked that he is
not getting nearly the same coverage
that this and that Emma Gonzales is
getting she has as of today nine hundred
and sixty eight thousand followers on
Twitter helped along by her celebrity
friends who all want to push gun control
so you can see the differential and
attention being paid to particular
victim certain victims get lots of
attention certain victims don't get any
attention because certain victims say
the right things that the cameras want
to hear when one of those victims one of
the the witnesses to the shooting a guy
named David Hogg you've seen him all
over TV he's been very loud he's been
saying some pretty absurd things and
over the weekend he was on CNN with
brian Stelter and Dan Rather for some
reason he's a journalism student I guess
and Dan Rather was there to advise him
on journalism which is sort of like
being advised on journalism by Stephen
glass why you're being advised on
journalism by a guy who's run out of the
industry in 2004 for putting forward a
fake letter about George HW Bush is
beyond me
but I guess that's what the media do now
we have to rehabilitate dan Rather
in any case David hog who's one of these
students he actually gets on national TV
and because he understands that his
agenda here his goal here is to push the
notion that guns are responsible and not
the police department suddenly he's
defending the cops for not doing their
job here's David Hogg defending the
police officers that way no one should
be doing this okay if a police officer
does something that is wrong then
everybody should be condemning that
police officer with a sheriff's deputy
does not run into the line of fire when
he has a gun and try and save students
he did something wrong and David Hogg
nobody else nobody is allowed to go out
there and exonerate this person for the
sin of letting children die when you had
the capacity to stop it and it was your
legal duty to do so which is what
happens here now I'm not talking about
whether it's suable I'm talking about
you were hired to do a job and you
purposefully did not do that job even
according to your own Sheriff who
himself is a garbage provocateur my hair
is David Hogg on CNN defending the
police officers and saying well I don't
really want to say anything about Scott
Israel no shocked he doesn't want to say
anything about Scott Israel Scott
Israel's on the same side as he is when
it comes to guns and if he goes after
Scott Israel then it may allow the press
to swivel their attention away from
their maniacal approach to gun control
and toward what actually happened here
so here's David Hogg he he just like
every other police officer out there at
heart he's a good person he didn't take
action in this event and I can't explain
why or I just can't explain there are no
words to explain why he wouldn't take
action to take out this individual but I
think it's a good example of how if he
didn't take action and supposedly for
others didn't I mean who does who wants
to go down the barrel of an ar-15 even
with a Glock and I know that's what
these police officers are supposed to do
but they're people too they need to
worry about themselves as well as all
the other students and I don't think
teachers need to have that
responsibility either so no one should
have the responsibility of facing down a
badge sure so who's gonna stop that bad
shooter I love this assumption that the
guns are magically gonna disappear from
society but they're not so who's gonna
stop the bad shooter it wasn't that long
ago that we forget that there was a
security officer with a Glock who
stopped the Congressional baseball
shooting is it that long ago that we
forget that it was an NRA member who
stopped a who shot a mass shooter in
Texas is it a lot of that long ago that
we forget that the vast majority of
these mass shooters are stopped
eventually by a cop most of them don't
end up shooting themselves usually two
police officers who have to do some
thing to stop these guys but I guess
that we're gonna pretend that David hog
gets to be the Pope now he's gonna he's
gonna provide indulgences he's gonna
provide old-school corrupt indulgences
all he has to do is sit around and pass
out indulgences all you have to do to
get an indulgence to say that you are
for gun control that's all you have to
do david hog really keeping the blame
where it belongs
he keeps attacking data lash like he's
on CNN's reliable sources and with brian
Stelter and there he defended the
sheriff again said that the sheriff
Scott Israel hadn't done anything wrong
but attacked anal lash again because of
course Dana is more responsible than the
sheriff whose job it is to actually
protect these kids and who failed
dramatically over and over and over and
over 45 times and then had a sheriff's
deputy there who didn't do anything and
maybe three more who didn't do anything
and then went on national television and
yelled about it here's David Hogg though
attacking Dana lash because it's really
Dana's fault here's when Dana's been
saying as the spokesperson for the NRA
she says that she wants to continue to
pass laws she wants people in Congress
to pass laws that help out with mental
health and things like that and she says
that she can't do that are you kidding
me you own these politicians you've
passed legislation that enables these
bum stocks which by the way aren't
allowed at NRA shooting ranges because
they're too dangerous that's how bad
they're but continuing on with my point
she wants Congress to take action and
she says that they want are you kidding
me she owns these congressmen she can
get them to do things it's just she
doesn't care about these children's
lives so I asked Dana if she owns
congressman can she get them to do
entitlement reform I mean so long as
she's got them completely in her pocket
can she push them for maybe some better
regulations yeah they're about a
thousand things that I could ask Dana to
do as long as she has Congress directly
in her pocket but that last statement is
really egregious and we're gonna discuss
that at length in just a second that
last statement where he says that Dana
doesn't care if children get killed this
is sick stuff and I understand you went
through a tragedy I understand something
bad happened to you that does not make
that statement any less immoral it is
immoral to sit around suggesting the
Dana lash does not care about dead kids
because she disagrees with David hog of
all people on gun control again I've
been saying this for a week and a half I
don't understand what about tragedy
somehow confers expertise on policy on
people I don't think it does I think it
confers expertise on suffering because
that's what you've done you have
experience in suffering but you don't
magically have knowledge about gun
control
or how it works you don't magically have
knowledge about gun policy after
studying the issue for half a second
half a hot second and then going on TV
and spouting slogans that you got from
Chuck Schumer's webpage and you
certainly don't have the moral
credibility under any circumstances to
impugn the intent of people who clearly
do care about the death of children you
know doesn't care about the death of
those kids the shooter you know doesn't
care about the death of those kids
presumably Isis but I promise you Dana
lash does care about the death of those
kids I even believe that Scott Israel
who I think is a schmuck cares about the
death of those kids I think he's a bad
guy I think he cares more deeply about
his own political career than he does
about the truth but I'm sure that he he
has that he was pained by the death of
those children but attributing those
motives to Dana it really is
immoral and this brings up a serious
problem with the entire debate that we
are currently having it is
self-contradictory we have all these
statements that are being put out there
one after another and they all
contradict each other and we are
supposed to pretend like they don't so
for example we keep hearing at the
Parkland shooting witnesses are taking
moral leadership of the gun control
debate these high school students
they've filled the gap left by the
adults there are new leaders they're the
people who should take super seriously
and then simultaneously we are told that
you must never criticize their
perspective because they're victimized
children so which is it are these those
brilliant wise and and wonderful among
us or are they or is it possible that
they could be criticized like which is
it are they innocent children and if
they are innocent children then wouldn't
that suggest we have to protect their
innocence rather than using them as
political shields it's so disingenuous
to go around saying these kids are the
new experts on gun control and then the
minute you say what they just said is
wrong or immoral or not true then it's
you who are the problem I'm not the one
who stepped in front of the camera after
a shooting and decided to to spout off
about gun control and that was not me
right I mean that that's my my job is to
comment on current events but these kids
put themselves in the public eye that's
fine that's their choice but being in
the public eye comes with criticism it
does have been doing it since I was
their age I understand that I got hit a
lot when I was a kid for all of the
things that I said politically and you
know what some of those were deserved
sometimes I was wrong
and there's this weird notion going
around that they can simultaneously cool
that they are the great moral arbiters
of society and the same time received no
blowback whatsoever that's not how the
First Amendment works
that's not how public debate works and
that's certainly not how politics should
work we cannot have a society if the way
we make policy is someone experienced a
tragedy therefore they are the new king
and potentate and they get to determine
what the policy is so pick one okay if
all of these witnesses are the moral
leaders then they also have to take the
slings and arrows that come with
speaking publicly hey how about this
people who are saying the parklands
shooting witnesses demonstrate that 16
year olds have important things to say
about public policy and they should vote
okay that's fine let's say that's true
let's let's pretend that's true for just
a second I'm gonna need to hear you make
the case why it is then that we should
raise the way in the age of being able
to obtain a weapon to 21 years old that
children should stand their parents
health insurance until they're 26 years
old and that teenage criminal should be
treated as juveniles you have to pick
one our kids adults or are they not
adults how about this one people on the
left suggesting that the police response
to the parklands shooting shows that
good guy with a gun can't stop a bad guy
with a gun all right then how do you
also argue that I should hand over my
guns to the authorities who are going to
protect me so if the good guys with the
guns can't stop the bad guys with the
guns why should I give my guns to a
bunch of the good guys who can't stop
the bad guys that makes no sense to me
I'm not handing my gun over to the same
police department that stood by while 17
people were slaughtered you gotta pick
one either you can trust the police to
protect you or you can't trust the
police to protect you here's another one
members of the NRA don't care about the
deaths of children in mass shootings
because they disagree with particular
policies the left wants and then we hear
from the same people that the media do
care deeply about the deaths of children
in mass shootings even if they continue
to show the names and the faces of
shooters regularly and engage in the
same sort of coverage issues and that
apparently make those shootings more
common by studies so which is it if we
are going to emotive two people based on
their activity if we're gonna say the
NRA doesn't care about school shootings
because their policies lead to more
school shootings not true but okay if
that's your argument then how can you
say that the media obviously do care
about mass shootings even when they
continue to show names and faces of mass
shooters on TV for ratings which is it
my understanding is the folks in the
media do care about shootings and maybe
they just
agree with me on how to treat those and
people in the NRA I care about shooting
Stu it may be they disagree with you on
how to treat those but you got to pick
one you can't you can't have it both
ways
here's another one David Hogg was
completely right to shellac taint a lash
of her culpability in the Parkland
shootings but he was also completely
right to ignore the culpability of
Sheriff Israel in the parkland shootings
these are the facts aren't out yet can't
have it both ways they're gonna blame
Danny you certainly have to blame the
sheriff who's in charge of all this crap
when it went down how about this the
shooting survivors claiming that Dana
and senator Rubio are morally inferior
human beings you don't care about the
mass slaughter of innocent kids but
Americans are doing something deeply
wrong if we question whether it's
appropriate for survivors to impugn asti
motives to those with whom they disagree
so in other words if you're a survivor
you get to impute whatever motive you
want to anybody else but if I say I'm
going to impugn a motive to you which is
a political motive to how you are
assessing blame then I'm the bad guy for
having politicized them work that way
the same people I mean again there's so
many contradictions that are being
offered by the gun control proponents
here none of these make sense
okay people who are saying
semi-automatic rifles must be banned
because they're so commonly used in mass
shootings but then say that if I say the
Second Amendment is under assault I'm
paranoid and crazy why would I possibly
think the government wants to take away
my rights why would I think I need a gun
to protect the government from taking
away my rights and then at the same time
they say the government should remove my
guns from my house explain that one I'm
slammed by the way side note here I said
an argument on line today from some dolt
that the Second Amendment should be
interpreted to give everyone a musket as
opposed to as opposed to the the rifle
that they currently have right that is
equivalent to saying it is the pure
equivalent of saying that we should get
rid of the internet we should get rid of
text messaging we should get rid of the
Telegraph we should get rid of the
telephone none of those are protected by
the First Amendment your ability to
speak on none of those is protected by
the First Amendment because none of
those things existed in 1791 it's a dumb
dumb argument another internal
contradiction from the gun control side
more armed security at schools they say
will not make our children safer but
then the folks in the media who say this
have armed security at every one of
their media outlets I know I've been to
all of them
CNN has great security MSNBC ABC CBS
they all have terrific security they're
not giving up those armed security
guards anytime soon at Northshore they
hey how about this one holding mass Town
Hall events with shoe mitt with mass
shooting victims and witnesses before a
stacked crowd of community gun control
enthusiasts is journalism it's not
activism it's journalism is what the
media maintain and folks at CNN said
what we did last week with that
Orwellian 2 minutes hate that wasn't
activism that was journalism but these
same people will suggest that it is not
journalism if you actually question any
of these victims or witnesses if you
actually ask them questions about their
views then somehow you are violating
journalistic ethics again none of these
contradictions can hold we have to be at
least in some minor way intellectually
consistent if we can't be intellectually
consistent we can't have a discussion if
we can't have a discussion this is
completely useless if we can't have a
discussion this is just a waste of time
but that's really what it is anyway it's
a politicized waste of time people are
attempting to to avoid responsibility
for the decisions that they've made the
the cop sheriff Israel that doesn't want
any of the responsibility the media
don't want any responsibility again if
in the end responsibility with the
shooting lies with the shooter and the
people who could have prevented it the
NRA are not the people who could have
prevented this I as a responsible gun
owner I'm not one of people could have
prevented this you know what I bought a
gun for the first time by the way you
know when I actually bought a gun I
actually bought a shotgun for the first
time after I had my gun debate with
Piers Morgan I did not own a gun up
until that point really didn't have a
gun because I grew up in LA most people
in LA don't have guns and I just didn't
grow up in the gun culture it wasn't
until I was threatened with death after
I said to Piers Morgan that there was a
Second Amendment right to own a gun that
I actually went and bought a gun and
that's why people are buying guns now
because they feel like they are being
assaulted for exercising their rights
they feel like they are being told what
to do by a government and by a media who
are intent on infringing their rights
and getting no safety in return it's not
even like they're trading their gun away
for safety that's how it's happening
they're trading their gun away and in
return they're getting the media's smug
moral satisfaction in preening that's
all we're getting here I mean I hesitate
to bring up Jimmy Kimmel again because
Jimmy Kimmel says the dumbest possible
thing about this kind of stuff but
yesterday he retweeted an account
suggesting the Republicans would take
money from Isis because that's the same
as taking money from the NRA and then
you wonder
why people are joining the NRA at record
numbers you wonder why people like me
are going out and looking to purchase a
rifle because when you say you're going
to infringe our rights and then you show
that you can't defend me of course I'm
going to go out and get another gun
okay now meanwhile there is some some
breaking news in the in memo gauge 2018
yeah it's been a little while since memo
gate and I know that you were excited
that we didn't ask you to do memo gate
but sadly we don't have to do memo game
the reason we have to do memo gate is
because there's a new memo out yeah
another memo how exciting now I'm going
to recapitulate what happened with the
memos in just a second but first they're
gonna have to go over to Daily wire and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wire comm when
you do you get the rest of my show live
you get the rest of Andrew Clavin show
live you get the rest of Michael Mills
is execrable show live you have to be
part of our mailbag all of those wonders
you get plus you get to ask us questions
when we have our conversations all of
these wonderful things and if you get
the annual subscription for $99 a year
you get all of those things plus the
magical leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr which is just phenomenal you'll
enjoy it in every possible way if you
just want to listen later for free go
over to iTunes SoundCloud YouTube
download subscribe leave a review we
always appreciate it we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
all righty so the let's recapitulate
what was happening a memo gate when last
we left our fascinating story
so I'm annoyed by memo gate I know there
are lots of people who are very into
memo gate memo 52018 I know everybody's
very into it the reason I was never
enthused about this is because I always
thought that the the allegations were a
little exaggerated recall the allegation
was that the FBI targeted then candidate
Trump or president-elect Trump in order
to discredit him over Trump brusha
collusion ties and they did so in
improper fashion they weren't actually
performing an honest investigation of
facts surrounding members of the Trump
campaign instead they were out to get
Trump now I've always had a few problems
with this number one if this is the case
Trump could have Declassified all the
materials proving it number two if
they're actually trying to get Trump why
didn't any of this material leak into
the public in the middle of the election
cycle that make a ton of sense to me but
that's the argument and so the argument
was forwarded by Devin Nunez Devin Nunes
is the is the House Intelligence
Committee chair and he wrote this four
page memo six page memo in which he
discussed supposed the FBI malfeasance
what did he accuse the FBI of doing what
he suggested is that there was a trump
former foreign policy adviser named
Carter page
Carter page was apparently connected
with Russia or in friendly with the
Russians going all the way back to 2013
when there was a FISA warrant found him
at that point
supposedly okay so Carter page was
investigated by the FBI then they took
out a FISA warrant on him no harm no
foul right well Devin Newton said there
was harm and there was fell he says that
basically the FBI took what is known as
the Steele dossier and they used it in
order to get the the the FISA warrant
against Carter page his argument was
that the Steele dossier was a compendium
of bad Intel that Christopher Steele who
didn't like President Trump and it was a
piece of Oppo research put together by
fusion GPS through Christopher Steele at
the behest of the Clinton campaign so
basically Hillary Clinton paid for
information that went from the Russian
government to Christopher steal that
information was used by the FBI to go
get a warrant against Carter Paige in an
attempt to tie together the Trump Russia
collusion narrative that's it that's the
accusation okay so he put out a memo a
few weeks ago I thought that the memo
was relatively weak I didn't think that
it completely proved the point I thought
that it made some serious allegations
about how
is a court to actually do the warrants
but it seems to me that they're very
loose about how they actually approve
warrants most courts are unfortunately
our Fourth Amendment rights are not in
particularly good hands but and that
said it didn't look to me like there was
anything that suggested the FBI was
specifically targeting Paige in order to
get to trump it looked to me more like
they suspected Paige they got a flimsy
warrant based on material they suspected
was true and it hasn't panned out yet
which happens is that scandalous is that
the end of the world didn't seem to me
so okay so the real accusation the most
damning accusation in the Nunes memo was
that the FISA warrant that was gotten on
behalf of the steel dossier when they
got the warrant
the FBI lied to the FISA Court right
that they lied to the FISA Court by
telling the FISA Court that the actual
steel dossier was not Apple research or
at least they didn't they didn't show
that it was Apple research so they
didn't say was Apple research if they
had said that and the court would have
taken it less seriously and then they
wouldn't have granted the FISA warrant
okay so now Adam Schiff who is in fact a
leaker he's a radical Democrat from
California he's from my district I
believe for the district over he has
come out with a new memo and his memo is
an attempt to rebut Devin Nunes memos
so here is what shift claims he claims
number one and this is true that the
page warrant did not start the Trump
Russia collusion investigation this of
course was acknowledged by by Nunes in
the original memo that the originally
the the investigation started in July
thanks to investigation into Trump
campaign adviser George papadopolis
having nothing to do with Carter page so
the idea that the entire Trump roster
collusion investigation is fruit of the
poisonous tree based on a bad FISA
warrant that's not the case they claim
number two is that the Steele memo was
not the sole basis for the FISA
application now this is a little more
unclear so Schiff a lot of the
information in his memo has been
redacted so he claims that the FISA
warrant wasn't gathered solely on the
basis of the Steele memo even though the
Steele memo was used according to Schiff
quote DOJ said in multiple sources to
support the case for surveilling page
but made only narrow use of information
from Steele sources about pages specific
activities in 2016 chiefly his suspected
July 2016 meetings in Moscow with
Russian officials they say is shift says
the FBI interviewed page a lot earlier
in March 2016 about contacts with
Russian intelligence now that's all
I see it looks a lot like the the steel
memo was actually very important to
getting the FISA warrant that doesn't
make it illegitimate it's possible that
the FBI believe the steel memo was
filled with real information because
steel had a history of working with the
FBI and passing them real information
that was good enough for them they
applied but then again there's the the
Nunes allegation that the application
did not include the fact that the steel
memo was that the steel dossier was
actually paid for by the Clintons
okay so Schiff goes on he says the
judges were not democratic hacks the
FISA warrant was approved four different
times by four different judges three of
them were appointed by Republicans so
this was not a matter of a partisan hack
job he also says there was no wiretap on
the Trump campaign because page was not
working for Trump at the time of
surveillance that claimed by Schiff is
probably the most I see of all because
the the warrants against page allows for
retroactive searches of his messages
including the time that he was on the
Trump campaign so page obviously was
being investigated for Trump campaign
connections also but then the biggest
claim that is made by Chef in this memo
is that he actually let's the
application speak for itself and this is
pretty damning to Newtons so Nunes memo
claims that the FBI did not tell the
FISA Court exactly how biased the
dossier process was the information
gathering process was he did not quote
the application shift quotes the
application here's what the application
said quote it says that Seale was quote
approached by an identified us person
this would be fusion gps as glenn
simpson who indicated to source one that
be steal that a us-based law firm had
hired the identified us person to
conduct research regarding candidate
ones ties to russia that's Trump the
identified us person and source number
one have a long-standing business
relationship the identified us person
hired source number one to conduct this
research the identified us person never
advised source number one as to the
motivation between behind the research
in the candidate ones ties to Russia
the FBI speculates now this is the key
the FBI speculates that the identified
us person was likely looking for
information that could be used to
discredit candidate ones campaign so it
says right there in the application let
me read that again slowly it says in the
application the FBI speculates that the
identified US person that be fusions GPS
is Glenn Simpson was likely looking for
information that could be used to
discredit candidate number ones campaign
that could be used to discredit Trump's
key
when I read that that says to me that
the FBI did in fact tell the courts that
this was Apple research that sounds to
me like them telling the court Apple
research it doesn't sound that to me
like they were hiding the ball it sounds
to me like legal language it was in a
footnote but no matter it's in the
document again would that have prevented
the court if the court knew that it was
Apple research would that have prevented
the court from actually granting the
FISA warrant no they would have said
okay we we trust the your source steel
right has worked with you guys before
and he's provided you good information
and we assume that you did some we
assume that you did some checking into
the veracity of the information now
here's where it gets a little bit
problematic for the FBI because they
didn't apparently do a lot of checking
into the information regarding the
allegations made in the sealed dossier
they just went straight to the FISA
Court now could that be a problem that
Andy McCarthy says yes over at National
Review Andy McCarthy is defending the
the Newton's memo he says that the FBI
should have told the FISA Court that the
Russians considered page an idiot in
which they had said in some intercepted
conversations they should have known the
steal dossier was nonsense because FBI
agent Bruce or worked for fusions GPS a
new steal did not want Trump to become
president so the FBI should have
revealed that still was biased against
Trump and that the FBI's language with
misleading since they knew Steele was
doing Apple research for Hillary and
also that Lisa Paige and Peter Struck's
bias remember these are the FBI agents
who are texting each other about how
much they hated Trump and that matters
because they worked on the investigative
team together well a lot of that is
speculation okay we just don't know the
answer to some of this we're gonna have
to call some of these people in front of
committees and have them testify there's
a perfectly plausible case to be made
that the FBI overstepped its boundaries
and that they probably do so a lot with
the FISA courts but the strong case that
was being made here was that the FBI was
out to target Trump again I don't think
the information is there to support that
allegation that allegation seems to me
still to be a little bit too weak so I'm
gonna wait for more information to arise
I'm gonna wait for more information to
come out and then we will see where we
are because I think that you know it is
done it is unclear to me you know
whether whether all of these allegations
are enough to discredit even the page
warrant forget about the entire Trump
Russia collusion investigation now by
the way do I think the Trump Russia
collusion investigation is going
anywhere I don't know with regard to
actual collusion again I see no evidence
of actual
I'm not sure Muller has either all of
the allegations that are currently being
made by the Democrats have so far been
unsuccessful
are for him working with the Russian
government before he knew Trump all of
the activity with Rick Gates involves
manna fort and the Ukrainian government
but nothing to do with Trump the George
papadopolis thing involves him lying to
the FBI but it's not clear at all that
he was funneling information up the
chain to trump Mike Flynn was indicted
not for corrupt carryings-on during the
campaign but for making a phone call to
the Russian government while he was
still in the transition period and then
lying about it to the FBI so he's
charged with obstruction
not even with collusion or any crime
that could they could plausibly be
called conspiracy so a lot of the a lot
of the talk about how the Trump Russia
investigation is is proceeding a pace
I think this ends with maybe some
obstruction charges against some folks
but I don't see this being the
blockbuster that the left really wants
so there is your update on memo gate
yeah I know fascinating right but it's
important to debunked this stuff because
you're seeing partisans on both sides
jump to conclusions people on the Left
saying obviously everything was fine and
people on the right saying obviously and
people on the right saying obviously
nothing was fine everything was was
garbage the FBI is a bad organization
all the rest I don't think either of
those things are true I think the FBI
cuts corners on a pretty routine basis
on FISA warrants and I think this is
another case of that I don't know that
it was an attempt to quote-unquote get
trumped by the deep state which is the
accusation that's currently being made
over and over and over by the way worth
noting and that the that the President
of the United States is talking about
various policies on gun control right
now and he's talking about arming what
he calls adept teachers the President of
the United States also talking about
using the gun violence restraining
orders the this is a topic that I have
talked about a little bit before the
recommended by David French over at
National Review
this was the policy that would allow
family members close friends to apply to
courts to temporarily withhold your
capacity to have a gun or buy a gun
based on your mental health this seems
to me perfectly reasonable the president
also made a comment today that was not
quite so reasonable where he suggested
that he would run into
that he was ripping into the deputy
again in parkland and he said I would
have run in there unarmed sure sure he
would mr. president yeah yeah no no okay
I don't want to mention things like bone
spurs I don't want to mention things
like your personal Vietnam being
avoiding STDs in the 70s but I have my
doubts that you would have run in
unarmed but are maybe I mean again this
is why I think that we have to have
professionals with arms who actually do
what they are supposed to do okay time
for a couple of things that I like and
then a couple of things that I hate and
we'll do a federalist paper so a thing I
like number one there is a movie that I
watched it's by Danny Boyle and it is
with Chris Evans Captain America who
apparently hates me for some reason that
I can't quite nail down and killing and
Murphy the movie is called sunshine and
it's it's a sci-fi movie the first
two-thirds of this movie is quite good
the last third of it is kind of dumb but
the first two-thirds of it are really
stylish and interesting and well-made
all right here's the basic premise is
that the Sun is burning out and we here
on earth have decided that we are going
to nuke the Sun which is pretty awesome
we're gonna send a giant nuclear weapon
into the Sun to reinvigorate the Sun and
it will all be fantastic so here it is
here a little bit of preview our Sun is
dying and kind faces extinction sixteen
months ago I Robert Capa and a crew of
seven left Earth frozen in a solar
winter our mission reignite the Sun
before it's too late okay so the movies
cool looking again it's Danny Boyle who
would go on to direct a Slumdog
Millionaire and a bunch of other kind of
interested in looking movies the movies
look is really interesting it turns into
a kind of rote monster picture for no
reason in the last third of the film but
there's some cool stuff in it and it is
I think the first two-thirds of it is
worth watching I will not say that the
entire movie is worth watching because I
wouldn't want you to waste half an hour
on on some pretty bad sci-fi horror okay
other things that I like is Malthus his
birthday today so congratulations to my
son Malthus for for finally reaching his
21st birthday now you can drink Malthus
how old are you actually Malthus it
okay so Malthus is 25 so in honor of
malthus's 25th birthday he gets to work
tomorrow
so congratulations to Mathis I did not
get him a present
other than this but this should suffice
because I mean this is the most famous
he's ever gonna be it's me talking about
him right now so Mathis congratulations
on your birthday and yes that's right
you get ripped even on your birthday
because you knew that though coming in
here today dude everybody knew that
okay so happy birthday to the best
producer at the company except for all
the other guys Mathis Glover well done
other things that I like California
Democrats I refusing to endorse Dianne
Feinstein which I find hilarious oh
she's been in the Senate since 1833
actually since 1992 she's one of the
most left-leaning members of the US
Senate
she was the sponsor of course of the
1994 assault weapons ban she has 100%
rating from near all pro-choice America
so she's a pro-abortion fanatic she has
a like a 7% rating from the Chamber of
Commerce powers something like she
doesn't and she looks suffice it to say
she's very left okay and the California
Democratic Party refused to endorse her
because she's not far left enough
because that's how insane Democrats are
if they want to lose elections they
should continue to can they should
continue to do this if Dianne Feinstein
in enough for you I don't know what is
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate and then we'll do a federalist
paper so all righty things that I hate
so today's things that I hate Ivanka
Trump went to north she went to South
Korea for the Olympics at the very end
of the Olympics and an Olympic skier
named Gus Kenworthy who apparently is
also the stuff he also stars as Robb
Stark apparently I guess in in Game of
Thrones you'll see what I mean when we
show a picture um he came out and said
what is it vodka Trump doing here well
what a vodka Trump is doing there is
that she's the daughter of the
presidents of the United States and
she's going there for the dwell I mean
like da but here he is whining about it
he says so proud of all these people
everyone here has worked hard to make it
to the Olympics and have the opportunity
to be at the closing ceremony well
everyone accepts it vodka honestly TF
she doing here what what a kind and
generous human being what a nice fellow
what is she doing at the Olympics you
know a celebration of the American
spirit just terrible how dare Ivanka go
to South Korea there was another
Olympian who came out and said that they
were very happy to see vodka that seems
a lot nicer to me when you're so
polarized that if I'm caught showing up
in South Korea is a disaster for you I'd
say your priorities are slightly
misplaced okay other things that I hate
for the second straight year
trans male on testosterone just won a
girl's state wrestling championship so
there is a girl who believes she is a
boy and she's taking testosterone in
order to in order to develop in more
masculine ways and she is not allowed to
wrestle with the boys because they
actually have biological they actually
have you know restrictions on biological
boys wrestling biological boys and so
she wrestles with the girls and of
course she won because she's on
testosterone now this is absurd
I mean it is absurd to have women who
are taking heavy doses of what would be
banned drugs if they were taking them
for athletic purposes suddenly being
allowed to wrestle girls who are not
allowed to take those drugs for
competitive purposes but this is how it
works now so this this woman this girl
who has muscles that are you know man
looking muscles let's put it that way
she just won the Texas class 6a
championship in the girls division for
the second year in a row she is on a
dosage of testosterone pursuant to her
transition then of course she had a
perfect 32 and a record against steroid
free girls she took on this season and
of course some people booed and some
people cheered the wrestlers mother has
argued the steroids are not really an
advantage sherds water and that
wrestling has more to do with skill and
discipline okay if that's the case then
why do we have to have separate
divisions at all maybe men should just
wrestle women since testosterone doesn't
matter and it's all technique hit men
have different body types than women and
testosterone gives you an advantage this
is why if you are at the Olympics and
you take testosterone you will be banned
from competition as many Russians were
okay
quick Federalist paper time so
Federalist number 17 we've been going
through a Federalist paper every week we
are already up to Federalist 17 in
Federalist 17 Alexander Hamilton makes
the case that it does not threaten the
Union to have a strong central
government that people should not feel
threatened by a strong central
government that may seem like a
laughable case to you now because the
central government is so strong and so
overpowering he claims that the federal
government would not want to interfere
in every part of our life and usurp
authority from the state she says quote
the administration of private justice
between the citizens of the same state
the supervision of Agriculture and other
and of other concerns of a similar
nature all those things in short which
are proper to be provided for by local
legislation can never be desirable cares
of a general jurisdiction he's saying
that state business is going to remain
state business and he also says that
because people are going to be more
loyal to States than they are to the
federal government
they will not take kindly to federal
usurpations of state power he says it is
a known fact in human nature that its
effect hey that is affections are
commonly weak in proportion to the
distance or is a few cygnus of the
object upon the same principle that a
man is more attached to his family than
to his neighbourhood to his neighborhood
then to the community at large the
people of each state would be apt to
feel a stronger bias toward their local
governments than towards the government
of the Union ok that obviously is not
true and what question now is why that
isn't true some of it is the Civil War
and the and the change in the balance of
power between the states and the federal
government some of which had to happen
in order to assure the rights of former
slaves black Americans but there's
something else that's happened too and
that is that Americans belief in their
local community has completely fallen by
the wayside as we become more atomized
as we engage less socially as we work
less with our neighbors our adherence to
community loyalty is dumped in favor of
adherence to broader national ideals I
would say and that's why you see local
communities being ignored so often in
favor of women's marches and and million
man marches or March for life marches
these widespread public events and draw
more people and more enthusiasm than a
lot of local events do now
because a lot of neighborhoods have
basically gone downhill and our kinship
to our neighbors has gone downhill as
well so issues that were solved at the
local level are now being solved in the
national of a part of that is because
the government in the 20th century has
grown so much that people have foregone
the possibility of doing stuff at the
local level part of that is because we
have stopped worrying about
inculcating virtue through local
community and instead we have abdicated
that duty to a vast powerful federal
bureaucracy okay so we will be back here
tomorrow I will give you the update on
University of Minnesota how it went and
if you're there night I'll see you there
look forward to it I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alexander Oh audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing